[applause]
Gibbs: Great.
Thanks, Andrew.
You know, that was
a pretty cool demo.
But actually, I'd like
to take that up a notch
and show you something that I
think is even more impressive.
So what I'm gonna do now
is I'd like to call up
Jay and Animesh from IBM.
And what they're gonna do
is they're gonna take
the same App
that you just saw Andrew
write,
the same Guest Book App,
and without modifying
a line of code,
they're gonna deploy that App
on premise
to the IBM WebSphere
application server
that's right on this box here.
So, guys, have at it.
Subrahmonia: Thanks, Kevin.
Hi. I'm Jay Subrahmonia,
and I'm the Director
for IBM Cloud Labs team
in our software group
strategy organization.
And as Kevin mentioned,
many of our Enterprise customers
typically want to run
the Java code
within the corporate firewall.
But they all want
the flexibility
of actually being able
to move their applications
between different environments
so that they get ready
for change
if they decide to make a change
for technical
or business reasons.
So today, Animesh and I
are going to demonstrate
how following standard Java
APIs and libraries
allows our Enterprise customers
to do precisely that.
Now, most of our
Enterprise customers
typically use WebSphere
as their application server,
DB2 as a database,
and Tivoli LDAP
to store user information
Now, WebSphere actually
is a full J2EE container.
But today in our demonstration,
we are going to be using it
in its most basic form,
which is as a servlet container.
And there are many servlet
containers in the market today.
You see App Engine, which
is an example of another one,
and there are others
in the marketplace.
But what we're going
to show you today
is how following Java standards
allows our users to
deploy code in one environment
and seamlessly move it to others
with making
very minimal changes.
So I'm going to invite Animesh,
my colleague here,
to show you this in action.
And we're going to demonstrate
in the context
of the same
Guest Book application
that Andrew showed you
and using WebSphere
and App Engine
as the two servlet containers
to do the migration
from one to the other.
Thanks.
Singh: Thanks, Jay.
Hello, everybody,
my name is Animesh Singh,
And I'm the Lead Architect
and Developer at IBM Cloud Labs.
So as Jay mentioned,
when you are building
a web application,
certain technical features
of business tools
may require you to move
between different environments.
But since all these containers
and databases
can work with standard Java APIs
and libraries,
redeploying from Google App
Engine to WebSphere
requires no code changes.
Let me show you.
So here I have
the exact same code
which Andrew used to run
his Guest Book Application.
What I am going to do is just
make a few config changes,
so this is the JDO config
or XML file.
So this information
which you have here
is specific to Google App
Engine, and it's commented out.
It just needs to be replaced
with this information
which is specific to DB2.
And if you see,
the information which we are
giving to this config file
is that this is a connection URL
for the DB2.
This is the connection
driver name,
DB2 user name,
and DB2 password.
And that's pretty much
what you need to change
in the config settings,
and then you need to add
a few extra Java files...
which are basically DB2
driver files.
So DB2 JASC Java file
and the corresponding
license file.
And that's it.
With that done, I have
the exact same application
running on this over here
which is running IBM WebSphere
and DB2.
Let me go to the
verticle URL.
So you will see
the exact same code,
same application
which Andrew showed you.
And I show you that you can do
the exact same things.
And that's it.
With that done, what I have
just shown you is
that thanks to standard
Java APIs and libraries,
writing an application
which can be moved from Google
App engine to WebSphere
is very easy.
Finally, my team wanted
to make it even easier
for App Engine developers
to deploy their code
to WebSphere.
So we have implemented
a number of lower level
App Engine specific APIs
and tools.
In fact, starting tomorrow,
developers can utilize
App Engines, users,
and data store APIs
to interface with Tivoli LDAP
and IBM DB2.
And it will be available
at the following URL.
Thanks.
[applause]